Paul Finebaum ESPN radio host Paul
Finebaum show and the voice of the SEC
joining us on the program good morning
Paul how are you I'm great by the way
I think the Matt rule hire is
unbelievable interviewed a number him a
number of times and he it's something
fascinating a couple weeks ago Dan he's
a huge college football fan obviously
her coaching he may be the only college
football coach I've ever known that
admitted that he listens to sports radio
uh to be at wjx in Birmingham you may
remember and we're still on there in the
afternoon when we had him on a couple
weeks ago he said yeah I drive to work
every morning and I listened to that
station in Birmingham Ken this is in
Waco Texas too it makes the decision
yesterday I don't think anyone was
surprised but I am curious just like it
was with Kyler Murray for a different
reason he was signing a baseball
contract but he needed that affirmation
he'd gonna be a top-10 pick once he got
that then I think he made the decision
that it was easier for him did to get
that affirmation from somebody that all
of a sudden you're gonna be a top 10
pick maybe a top five pick don't go back
to Alabama I think he got as close to
that as possible what was really strange
about this story is a week ago as
Alabama was getting ready for the Citrus
Bowl the official spin out of Tuscaloosa
was simply that he was coming back and
then a lot of other people were as well
and I think I was just false enthusiasm
kind of like the night of your high
school prom and everybody you know grabs
hands and drinks cheap wine and says
we'll be best friends forever and the
next day you go off to college and never
speak to the guy again and I think too I
got caught up in that and it's always
worth remembering something about - and
I don't mean this to be disparaging Lee
toward his family but his father runs
the show yeah and and I think the father
took a good long look he got what he
heard he got what he wanted
last Friday where - went to New York to
be seen by a specialist he got the wink
in the nod that things are moving along
and progressing and I also think there
was a fun
I'm a marketing side to it as well
within about two hours after announcing
that he was leaving he signed what Leigh
Steinberg most people may have forgotten
but that was the the subject of the
Jerry Maguire movie and I think there's
a lot to be made off the field as well
the two is a charismatic guy Dan and I
think the numbers that he will make off
the field are pretty significant I'm
curious who you think what quarterback
benefited the most from the talent
around him because I've said all along
if LSU ever got a really good
quarterback then we would you know be
really amazing because we'd see all of
these wide receivers in the NFL and we'd
go oh they went to LSU I never knew that
you know Clemson's got a lot of talent
Alabama's got a lot of talent so out of
Chula Joe Burrell and Trevor Lawrence
who do you think benefited more from the
talent they had around them I think it
was probably burrow because to to me
throws one of the prettiest passes I
have ever seen about only one more thing
on what you just said I had a I had
somebody come with me into your a couple
of weeks ago
he said Oh Beck I'm really play at LSU I
said yes he did
he said I don't remember him being there
because that was every wide receiver
that played under Les Miles that's a
great question I think Trevor Lawrence
is a generational quarterback I think
too is Joan twirled had the best season
I've ever seen and I'm not doubting him
I swear because I didn't see him have a
bad series the entire football season
but yeah I think Joe Burrell would you
became part of a system that worked
perfectly and you've heard Joe Brady's
good the the young guy who came over
from the Saints but what he did in
addition to calling great players
he changed the fundamental way LSU
receivers caught balls I mean he drilled
that into their heads in the offseason
and that made it easier for Joe burrow
who who was flawless so there's very
little wiggle room between that between
the answer to that question though the
greatest season turned in by an SCC
quarterback is who I'm going Joe Burrell
may be a nose hair ahead of camp due to
in 2010
did absolutely nothing wrong the only
thing he did wrong the entire season
against his head coach is a warning he
tried to he tried to dive over on the
next to the last play of the national
championship game against Oregon to be
the hero and it turned out he was
stuffed and they kicked a chip shark
ship chip shot he'll go to win you think
you couldn't put man cells
season up there
[Music]
yeah what put it up there I mean in
terms of pure excitement I'm not sure
I've ever seen anything like it but you
know man the difference was even though
Manziel and A&M beat Alabama in
Tuscaloosa they they also dropped a game
or two that they probably shouldn't have
hehe had a really rough game so I'm
trying to remember where it was it's
only been seven or eight years but it to
me cams was nearly by the way I mean
camp didn't lose one game excuse me cam
did not lose a game but he but he never
had a bad game though
and Joe Burrell never Joe Burrell never
had a bad series so those are two those
are the two bats I would put Manziel in
there Tebow is a little hard to quantify
because you know what he did was so
unorthodox and he had a lot of talent
around him as well and he know he was
great player but he had hit a pro team
around him there in Florida yeah the
state of the union in Alabama with
Alabama not playing next week for the
national title you got your quarterback
who's leaving I know that they got other
quarterbacks in a five-star who's coming
in but is there any nervousness there
with Alabama's it just reload it's
really low but I think it's a little bit
of beating your head against the wall
and saying I feel better when I stop and
I don't mean to right I'm not I'm not
right it's a burn off but he's won two
of the last seven titles Dan that's
great that's that's a career almost
anyone else but if dabbler Sweeney is
celebrating next Tuesday morning in New
Orleans the national championship that
will be three out of four years you tell
me which one wins in a game of coaching
poker and and I think that's that's the
greatest fear Alabama fans don't really
know
who to cheer for they don't like these
because they really dislike plums and
even more because Clemson is the one who
a year ago today beat them by 28 points
and Alabama is still trying to figure
out what happened that night in Santa
Clara but I still people think I'm crazy
when I say this that if I'm Davos
Sweeney
if Alabama is open and Nick you know
steps down in the next two years or so I
know that he's supposed to go back there
but I'd be like I would not leave
Clemson to go back there no you're not
crazy you're you're very smart for
saying that there's no way he'll go back
here a couple of years ago I thought he
would I stand with him at a banquet two
years ago where he was inducted into the
Alabama Sports Hall of Fame and he was
teary-eyed and emotional as family was
there it was you know it was a big
moment for him but that was that was a
national championship ago and the second
one really does it's like you know
winning you wouldn't you know yeah one
number one hit with a million a million
people have had that well not that many
but quite a few having another one
really solidifies you and and he's now
in rarified air to go back he's got a
great a situation as any coaches ever
had he's beloved if you've been there
and it's it's just an unbelievably cool
place where the only thing that matters
is college football and to go to Alabama
to follow Saban is insane
in all the great transitions in history
whether following wooden or or or Bryant
or any one of the the icons in college
history I think this would be the
toughest because I mean Alabama fans
aren't really happy right now and they
went 11 and two destroyed Jim Harbaugh
in a bowl game will finish and you know
probably six or seventh in the rankings
I have the number two recruiting class
and it feels like Armageddon I know I
know
by the way you've got an early Christmas
gift this year oh yeah I did I guess
you're talking about Jim Harbaugh no oh
Lane Kiffin
yeah that was christmas hanukkah kwanzaa
birthday anniversary all wrapped into
one it's too easy all you need to do is
bring back spurrier you know you know
then yeah I've been made they talk about
luck for kiffin he hires DJ Durkin from
the Maryland coach who was fired in any
other on any other day of the year that
would be the biggest story in college
football or at least within the state by
the end of the day Mississippi State had
fired its coach and Kevin it was just
sitting there going isn't anyone gonna
criticize me I mean he he it's it's
going to be everything Lane does is a
reality show but this is going to be
even more dramatic wait what was the
horrible I know you and Harbaugh go at
it yeah I just Harbaugh playing save it
last week and you know New Year's Day
bow that was that was I mean it's always
I mean I used to really kind of you know
a little bit of schadenfreude it was
horrible when he lost but now now Dan
it's it's like I wish you would just
beat somebody because I mean how many
times can you go on a radio show and go
Jim Harbaugh lost again to a top ten
team I mean it's becoming one of the
it's like the record on the record just
keeps skipping over and over again so
it's it's no longer really entertaining
you are Paul though and we appreciate
your time as always thank you enjoy the
national title game who do you have I
can't wait here I don't expect that to
change Dan it's a pleasure to be on with
you I really appreciate thank you bunch
Happy New Year best Paul Finebaum he's
an ESPN radio host all playing bomb show
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]